Speaker 1: Let's hear from some folks via
discord. If you'd like to talk to me. The
way we do it is via discord. You can subscribe
free to the discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. And from that point forward, you will
have the opportunity to speak to me. Let's do
that right now. I want to start today with
our caller from Atlanta named Taylor Taylor.
You're on the air. What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: Oh, boy. Hey. This is David,
can you hear me back then, right?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hey, great. Thanks for taking. Well,
Michael has been mulling over the situation
with current events. And I'm just I've
been drawing a comparison between, I guess,
you know, 9/11 and today as both. Two big, big
events, huge tragedies really to impact us and
just the different responses that we've had. So
back with 9/11, if you remember those commercials
with, you know, I'm an American and it didn't
matter who it was, essentially non partizan. I
mean, everybody was behind. The I guess you could
say the goal of whatever the goal was up until the
invasion of Iraq, I'd say, but then today it's
just I mean, such a stark contrast that we're
seeing. And as you've shown, I mean, you can draw
a line and it's so partizan now that we have,
you know, something to go against. But it's
just so weird how it had lines been drawn.
So my question to you, as somebody
who covers these types of events,
is the differences between today and then, do
you find it? It's more of just the. The situation
of what caused it say, you know, something I guess
may be tangible, as in the case of a terrorist
attack, a threat on safety versus, you know, a
virus you can't see with the naked eye, which
is still a threat on safety.
And we have like a unified goal,
but we're seeing such a different response to it.
Speaker 1: Yes, I think that for the most part,
this is related to the sort of debasing of actual
policy and the move into cultural issues. And as
Rachel Bit of Cougher talk to us about earlier
in the week, just basically focusing on optics
and talking points. And so you are right that one
might have thought that in a nine 11 like way,
the pandemic might have really united
left and right. I mean, listen,
much like there are pandemic conspiracies, there
are also 9/11 conspiracies. That's not different.
But the degree to which people were
united in the immediate aftermath of 9/11
seems almost inconceivable today. I mean,
even attacking doctors, you know, all of this.
Speaker 3: Exactly that. Exactly.
Speaker 1: Listen, I have to ask,
are you calling from an aviary at
which construction is taking place?
Speaker 3: It seems that way, sitting out back,
surrounded by a lot of cardinals right now,
Speaker 4: got
Speaker 1: the call. I appreciate it. All right,
very good. An interesting one to start with. Let's
go next to I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly.
Is it Saurabh from Austin, Texas.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. Yeah, it's a Saurabh.
Speaker 1: OK, great. Well,
welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Yeah, thank you. I have a question
regarding homelessness problem that is sweeping
across different parts of the nation, major
cities. What would be the long term and
short term solutions for homelessness?
Speaker 1: Well, I think that this is a great
question, because the short term and the long term
is different in the short term. We've learned that
it's cheaper to just pay for housing for homeless
folks and also to pay for health care for homeless
folks. Now, unfortunately, if you're like a right
wing Moral Majority type person, you would say,
well, they don't deserve that. They haven't earned
that. But there's numerous studies that show
the societal cost in terms of having people on the
streets uninsured, visits to the emergency room,
police calls, etc. It's cheaper to just house
people. Now, that's not really a long term
solution necessarily. I think on the longer term,
we really have to look at either government jobs
programs, universal basic income. In some
cases, it's about minimum wage, it's about
economic restructurings, know it's about a lot
of bigger things that take a much longer time.
That's how I would distinguish between the
short term and the long term on homelessness.
Speaker 4: OK, thank you.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you
for the call. Yeah, did you have something else?
Speaker 4: And thank you for being out there
and representing not just my
type, but also my hairstyle.
Speaker 1: Oh, beautiful. Yeah, I don't
even. What is the name of the hairstyle.
Speaker 4: I don't know. It's just
woke up and a little bit of color.
Speaker 1: Very good. I think I just woke up
and a little bit of comb. All right. Thank you,
Sarabhai. Appreciate it. Yes. All
right, very good, beautiful phone call.